so from puppets unlike anything you've
ever seen to taking three months to film
one 10 second shot there is no denying
the amount of love and attention that
went into building the world of
Pinocchio Pinocchio is definitely one of
a kind this puppet's joints may appear
wooden but in reality his entire body is
made out of metal and it was designed on
a computer before it was printed out in
3D did you know Pinocchio is actually
the first puppet fully printed out of a
3D printer like how cool is that
Pinocchio himself is the first puppet
fully printed out of a 3D printer when
it came to his design Guillermo del Toro
took plenty of inspiration from the
artwork of Grace Grimley all while
making it a priority that Pinocchio
actually needed to have an unfinished
look Geppetto in this version carves
Pinocchio while he's intoxicated and so
he starts with the ear and his hair and
he is really careful with that but then
he finishes him quickly while that was
quick this one 10 second shot took
roughly three months to film but two
months of that was actually spent on
setup and it took about a month to shoot
it in this Frame the monkey spazatura
passes through the carnival on his way
to meet Volpe for the first time and
according to Guillermo del Toro we have
to negotiate A Clockwork operation to
make that shot happen most of the
puppets had been placed on small cranes
and all of the rigging needed to be in
motion at once and while this may have
seemed ambitious all that was very much
influenced by the way Guillermo shoots
live action films so if the dogfish
puppet had actually been built to movie
size it would have been larger than the
freaking building so instead these
Geniuses worked with a highly detailed
but scaled down version it turned out to
be about three and a half feet long
while when it came to animating the
water around the puppet we came up with
the digital solution relying on CG and
other effects to make it blend with the
stop motion seamlessly Guillermo del
Toro revealed that the dogfish's design
was actually heavily influenced from a
Time Gone by when explorers would draw
the marbles of the sea exaggerated and
more Whimsical so Pinocchio actually
relied on two different animation
techniques for the puppet's expressions
for most of the characters the British
Studio McKinnon and Saunders provided
their one-of-a-kind system of Gears
which was no bigger than a walnut that
can be fitted beneath a silicone head
and turned to create the sort of nuanced
emotions that we can see on screen for
the main puppet however the animators
actually took a different approach
Pinocchio is replacement because he's a
wooden boy according to Georgina Haynes
the creative supervisor a silicone head
skin that sits over mechanics wouldn't
look like Wood anymore and so they just
simply swapped out the puppet's face
depending on his expression now Volpe is
actually a combination of three
different villains from the original
story as Guillermo del Toro explained
the three main villains in the original
story are the cat the fox and the
Puppeteer and we want to defuse them
into one and so his design included
elements from each of these characters
in particular the fox can be seen in the
way that his hair shoots up almost like
ears but as Mark Gustafson the
co-director explained he's kind of the
Devil in a way and his hair resembles
horns too so the animators for Pinocchio
so we're pretty much the same as actors
Guillermo del Toro encouraged them to
Think Through the puppet and avoid
pantomime to give us relaxing the
animators had to pay really close
attention to which one among them seemed
the most compatible with a specific
character oh that person's really got
Pinocchio down that's our Pinocchio even
the voice cast acknowledged the amount
of work that the animators put into the
characters considering Finn wolfhard
said at least in the making of it I
played such a small part in it the real
actors and everyone in it to me are the
people that really shaped all of the
characters physically so the Crickets
dance number during the credits is one
of the few choreographed scenes for the
most part the dance sequences in the
movie weren't fully planned out
beforehand because the production team
knew that there would be specific Beats
from the script that they would have to
hit okay so like for example during the
song that Pinocchio sings when he first
meets Geppetto the animators knew they
wanted him to smash a series of bottles
with a hammer before jumping and
swinging on a rope and so for anything
else surrounding that that evolved a
little bit more organically as we went
honestly you can tell a lot about a
scene just from its lighting when Carlo
goes into the church for the first time
we had this very warm light coming into
the church this scene is meant to
contrast the moment when Pinocchio's
first introduced to the townspeople and
the light that we see streaming through
the church Windows is like much cooler
to make for a Grimmer mood Frank passing
ham the cinematographer has admitted
that it was the natural light in the
film that posed his greatest challenge
mostly because natural light is always a
movement and because of the amount of
precision it required to capture and
stop motion animation Sebastian J
Cricket couldn't be too small if he was
you wouldn't be able to see all of those
gorgeous facial details that were
designed by the illustrator guy Davis as
it was guy already had to make the
cricket just a little simpler than the
other characters due to his size with
his mustache representing mandibles
while also being his main form of
communicating his feelings rather than
shrinking the cricket the animation team
decided to make Pinocchio even bigger
this is our Pinocchio to interact with
the cricket which is this height but
that being said multiple puppets had to
be made in varying sizes for pretty much
every character then we have these small
crickets for other shots that for
Sebastian J Cricket he sure went through
a lot in this movie huh oh the pain life
such hideous pain though maybe not quite
as much as his book counterpart so in
the book Pinocchio crushes the cricket
right away and he only reappears later
as a ghost well the movie didn't quite
go that far of course but the repeated
gag where he gets crushed and survives
stunt crickets were made using
claymation one-off heads that could be
frame by frame squashed for the body the
animators used a hollow skin of silicone
with aluminum wire and metal Armature
underneath this actually allowed them to
literally squash the body and then the
wings which were pre-bent in very
intentional crushed shapes okay so early
into production it was decided that they
were going to keep the color schemes
really rigid Guillermo del Toro
explained the blue is only for those
elements that are magical or shaping
Pinocchio red was only for war and
destruction Geppetto's Village relies on
a number of warm Shades like Golds and
ambers while volpei's Carnival is filled
with vibrant oranges and green so if you
pay close attention you might even
notice that the color scheme of the
characters themselves often correspond
with their environment for instance each
of the magical characters have the same
otherworldly blue violet purple skin
because they're all related one mistake
in costuming affected the entire
direction of the movie Georgina Haynes
recalled how a sample fabric had been
sent to her from McKinnon and Saunders
or spazatura's pants and Haynes realized
she'd stitched it together with a
slightly uneven line in it Haynes said
that she found the fabric beautiful and
described it as Perfectly Imperfect this
led the animators to realize that was
what we wanted the lines to look like in
our film a picture of the sample fabric
was then sent around to every Department
with Haynes referring to it as a pivotal
reference so the world of Pinocchio
needed to feel like one that really
existed right Georgina Haynes did plenty
of research into towns in Northern Italy
around the film's time period so that
she can could build a setting that was
sort of a huge mix of all sorts of
different Inspirations I Know Places
just like this Guillermo del Toro
revealed that plenty of thought was put
into establishing a sense of history
about the village as well explaining
that you can see structures ranging from
medieval ruins to 18th century carvings
and then you have murals from the 1500s
1400s so it feels layered so that
filming process was anything but easy
huh but which part of the World building
do you think was the most effective we'd
love to hear your thoughts so make sure
to let us know down in the comment
section
okay